let's started thinking about arguments
after you get past chapter 4 part 1
these guys are engaged in heavy-duty
arguments about the resistance and the
nature of God and it goes on pretty well
until part 11 and at the end of part 11
Damien gets irritated and says I've had
it with you guys I'm leaving and then
they sort of wrap things up so we're
going to look at what's going on mainly
from Part two and three all the way to
211 we're going to try to get through as
much of it as possible we're laid out a
plan over here if we don't get solve it
that's okay
before we do that so I'm some sort of
general remarks so I think you guys have
gotten this from not just this last but
other classes that you're taking but
your writing classes for example that
you're required to make arguments and
make a case for something we often say
tell me why you think this that's asking
you to make an argument and when you're
making an argument you're giving some
sort of premises some sort of starting
points and you want these to be things
that aren't just ideas that you have you
want these to be things that your
audience can can agree about otherwise
you're never going to get going right if
you start out with a premise like I am
the greatest person in the world now any
particular person who says it and with
the people around them to believe that
probably now right so you're not going
to get off the ground with some argue
another I'm the greatest person in the
world the greatest person deserves
everything that coffee over there is a
part of everything give me that coffee
that's not going to fly that's an
argument but it rhetorical it's a
terrible argument is you're not going to
get anybody to accept that conclusion
they might actually be willing to give
you the coffee if you just ask them
nicely you don't
for that right when we want to convince
people of things that we believe and
they don't believe we start looking for
grounds that we can use that they do
believe that they do accept or they're
willing to at least accept for a while
see where they're going and that we want
to bring them to this conclusion that's
the way these arguments are going and
the conclusion in these arguments
typically is something like God exists
there we're talking about whether God
exists or not the existence of God the
being of God and philosophical arguments
about God quite often Vera is their God
involved is there any such thing Hume is
a bit more interested in this question
what sort of God are you talking about
that's what a lot of the discussion in
the course of these arguments bears on
are you talking about a god who's some
first clause but about whom we can't
know very much like Damien thinks are
you talking about the God who is a
designer and perhaps not as infinite or
perfect or anything like like that you
know the traditional conceptions of got
away clean these things or could God be
a gigantic spider spinning the cosmos
out of some sort of web you know the way
that filo proposes or perhaps they is
because a superannuated Danny that in
senile so you know they Eddie who
created the world you know sort of a
last effort and then died off you know
it matters an awful lot the way you've
actually think about God and when people
get into these arguments and they want
to convince other people that God exists
or they want to convince people that God
doesn't exist something that often gets
left out of the picture
is well what exactly do you mean by this
are your arguments leading towards the
same conception of God that we're
interested in you know if for example
let's say you're arguing against God
this is not an argument that Hugh makes
sometimes people will argue that God
can't possibly exist because human
beings clearly have some sort of need or
investment in thinking that there's a
God so therefore you know most things
that we we have a need or investment in
thinking about don't actually exist you
know they don't exist the way that we
think that they do they're certainly not
necessary there's a lot of wish
fulfillment right this is Freud's
conception among other people now if you
actually look at the kind of you know
ideas of God that people like that put
forward it tends to be the guy who gives
us everything we want is that all there
is to traditional conceptions of God is
it the god of you know God don't you
give me a mercedes-benz you know is that
Joan Baez sorry you guys heard that song
before the whole song it's kind of spoof
you know this woman who's praying and
she says God won't you give me a
Mercedes Benz and she's got some sort of
explanation for why she needs that and
then house on a hill and then even
remember what else is in the song
there's a few other things now he's got
like the you know the big cosmic
dispenser you know though the social
worker the welfare provider these are
going to go and then you know hand in
the right form and say here you go can I
can I have the stuff now that's a
cassette pens that conception of God
some people do it yeah all right now
somebody's arguing against that
conception
yeah and you don't believe that God is
like that you actually say that's a
really bad conception of God you know if
you see things that way
you're kind of in a dollar there is
their argument really taking any hold
against your consumption of God
no they're arguing against something
that they imagine religious people but a
lot of religious people don't you notice
is you know looking at Klan Thais and
Dania religious people can have very
different conceptions of what God is
like you know so we want to be clear
about what cane of God we're talking
about and the existence of God and the
the nature or our attributes or essence
of God are going to be somewhat
different from each other when we're
looking at this so that's one thing to
keep in mind
another thing I want to do a little bit
of review because these terms are going
to get used so much mm-hmm remember last
class we talked about a priori and a
posteriori and we didn't we didn't
really talk about these earlier this
semester that we could have it becomes
necessary because human uses these terms
so much in the course of the discussion
so what is a priori you guys remember
what that comes from slack-jawed is from
or by or with well the logic is is
something that falls under the off
priori yeah reasons reasoning all the
reasoning can be done in a posterior as
well when you see that word there yeah
that would be an option stereo re yeah
yeah it's basically unreasoning it comes
before red that's that's prior to the
priority in their posterior means after
and why would it be based solely on
reasoning because coming after
experience coming before experience so
you don't need any experience of
something to make an operatory argument
that's why logic mathematics would fit
under that you know for instance none of
you have been to Somalia right what are
we doing about Somalia what's up there's
Mike it's okay now that we're onto
something
what a pirate to do okay
so you don't you haven't been to Somalia
you don't actually have any experience
of Somalis
or actually probably even pirates right
funny doesn't even run across a pirate
you seem like movies and things like
that yeah and let's see how would we
make this work
there's a good dilute people know okay
so now there's a lot of sometimes big
man here but just go with me on this so
we've got you know Somali is full of
pirates pirates loot people looting
people's a bad thing
there for Somalia is full of bad people
that would be an upgrade are we're not
worried about that this point whether
it's true or false good they had
anything like that I'm just using this
to get across the point notice we
haven't actually experienced anything if
we actually went to Somalia to start
looking around are you a pirate
no are you a pirate you know maybe our
premises have bad now we're actually
starting to appeal
to experience we can make all sorts of
arguments based on appeals to experience
if you pull the dog's tail that's
probably going to happen to you
doc gonna bite you yeah unless it's a
really nice dog how do you know this I'm
willing to bet somebody pull dogs tails
did you already watched another kid pull
the dog's tail the dog Karen I'm fed up
in here like I told you blows Dale you
know you have experience about that sort
of thing again it's kind of still the
example but you see that would be an
Aquos territory argument when you tell
your child
now a little Johnny fluffy doesn't like
it when you pull his tail
and he will he will like you and Johnny
says I don't believe you say look I've
seen a lot of kids get bit when they
pull the tail fluffy is a dog dogs don't
like that but go ahead and try and pull
the tail it gets bit I told you so I
made it a posterior or argument to you
you know the basis of good experience
it was not a certain argument you might
not get bit this time but I was pretty
reasonably sure that you were gonna get
Ben that was the conclusion of my
argument so you see the difference
between these now why does Hume so
interested well let's think about what
we're making arguments are we arguing
about pirates or dogs and tails or
things like that
light bulbs shirts desks things in the
world to a certain degree but what are
we trying to get at with these arguments
in this dialogue the nature of God yeah
now when we talk about God why is it
that we have so many different
conceptions of God and those conceptions
tend to be kinda hard to get our heads
around fuzzy God isn't like a couple
or you know somebody says hey you need
to try some god this is really good god
mmm
yeah that's that's that's that's filling
me up it's just what I needed it inside
not my life is all trash doesn't quite
work like that doesn't everybody
everybody the miracle worker
there's something that we can't do he
can do for us yeah there's there's an
issue to God the God were the gods
however you can see with the divine our
seen as being and somewhat transcendent
having powers beyond the kind of powers
that we have or understand this is often
called the God of the gaps sort of
notion that well we can't explain
something so got it you know a miracle
happen and that's the sort of a lack of
intelligibility used to explain a lack
of intelligibility rather than actually
filling anything yet until we actually
know something about the nature of God
so God is transcendent in power to our
experience if God created the universe
that's a pretty big thing we understand
creation of you know like you could
probably figure polished Rock was made
right every one of you where did it come
from the materials for it you guys know
what's up top so ya know if it was
chocolate you're right cocoa plan the
truck what does this mean up here
calcium carbonate which is its kind of
stone limestone very good and now this
doesn't look like limestone so what did
they have to do they must have grounded
off and they you know kind of swish the
damn it I don't know
about that but I think the rest of you
probably have some idea about how it got
round like that and then straight when
they do that some sorting out since
reform and price and they do it mass
production okay so you understand that
pretty well notice it's something you've
proved you haven't been to the truck
Factory have you the name you take a
field trip
no you figured it out right because
things in the world were able to
understand pretty well on the basis of
our experience and even if we don't have
a lot of experience we might be able to
do some some reasoning about it
something that created the whole
universe that's a whole different
ballgame isn't it that's a little harder
to to make sense of you know God is
supposed to be ultimately good perfect
do we experience that in our ordinary
existence do you know anybody is
perfectly good probably know some people
that are really good I hope you know
does your life is enriched by that but I
don't think we know anybody was
perfectly God supposed to be perfectly
good this is hard stuff to make sense
out so if we're going to make arguments
and we want to base them on experience
we want to make arguments awful story we
gotta worry about how representative is
my experience how much connect strap
away from the little bit of that I've
experienced or even all my friends and
and colleagues and co-workers have
experienced all the way to you know some
sort of transcendent being who I can't
actually like you know go and say get
into outer space and look around all
there's job you know that's not going to
work I can't verify it on the basis of
experience like that when it comes to a
priori arguments human is very
suspicious of those two because he says
and this isn't the only position you
could take on this he says any sort of
arguments that are not based on
experience and you're just thinking
about how things have to be connected
together what he calls connections
those could be different you could
imagine them different than they are
thinking about the world that we
currently live in there are certain laws
of nature certain processes that take
place all the time right
could they be different than they are
can you conceive of that as being
different than they are if you can
conceive of them as being different view
says then there's a possibility it's
possible that they could be different
even though they aren't and that means
that they're not necessary things you're
not going to be able to really reason
from them hoc priori with any sort of
certainty and you could you know come up
with any sort of argument you like for
whatever you like and that means you're
not going to really get anywhere now in
this this dialogue damia is saying hey
we want these kind of truce and they ask
these is saying we want these countries
and filo is criticizing both of them and
both of those guys are also criticizing
each other so now what we want to do
after all this is look at some of these
these arguments see how they how they
get put together how they stand out so
let's think first of all just to get
these out of the way about these
priority arguments
yeah Damien is sort of a in many
respects a traditional theologian he he
likes the idea of a career and arguments
arguments that you can come up with on
the basis of reason alone because those
ought to be convincing no matter what
your experiences so in traditional
apologetics which is you know getting
arguments for for
doctrines of the faith you see a lot of
people still these days making these
arguments those a little bit like a
conversation in a coffee shop between
you know a Christian and his atheist
friend and the atheist will say I just
don't really even God and the Krishna
say well consider all these things
around you
you know all of them they have a clause
don't think he says yeah
maybe I'll have a clause well you know
what caused them well you know they're
made out of matter or somebody made them
this way or there's some sort of you
know purpose behind making you know the
coffee cup and all that or evolution or
pick whatever you like and then you know
the Christian will ask another question
saying okay that's fine you've
identified causes that lead to effects
not what caused that cause and I'm a an
atheist we'll think a little bit more so
well you know laws of nature okay what
clause there and you can keep on pushing
it back further and further further
right now you're not relying on
experience to do that you may you may
rely on experience at the very start
with this this is what we call a
cosmological argument or DK's point is
is this so we have a facts and clauses
but it cause itself is generally and
effect of some other laws right and that
can be an effect
just popped into existence randomly does
that make sense that just is that way
well you know and when you come to that
it just is that way that that sort of
undermines our desire for
intelligibility for making sense out of
things and you know Damien wants to say
that that we actually can't understand
at least that there has to be some sort
of ultimate co-op what do you cause the
Big Bang and the Big Bang would have to
be explained wouldn't it you're not
gonna get very far good to say well a
Big Bang happened why did it happen
Valley the matter is it's only eternal
laws and rules and things that look like
really apples get there you can keep on
pushing it back sooner or later
you have to arrive at something that
you're willing to say okay here's the
bedrock this is what got the whole thing
going there's some sort of ultimate
cause something at the very end of this
chain that makes things the way they are
there's also a further problems here
that that data points out to not only do
you have to have some sort of ultimate
cause you also have to explain how this
whole chain in itself works I mean is
there some reason why these clauses are
arranged in the order that they are in
relation to each other what brought that
about there has to be what he's looking
for is some sort of the word here
necessity spell necessity
some sort of necessary being no we're
not necessary the eggs right you didn't
have to exist the way that you do you
know if your parents haven't gotten
together then you wouldn't be who you
are if you know let's say you know your
each other you know you know what
happens after that and then there you
are
what does it like somebody else instead
I said I don't have a child with this
person
rather a child with this person there
wouldn't be any you know it's not only
does it be a different view there would
be in you right it's not like you'd have
you know dark hair right and he'd have
blonde or something like that there
wouldn't be any yeah there wouldn't be
any you there'd be other things instead
what about you know even we trace it all
the way back to the Big Bang well what
if the Big Bang never happened and you
don't get anything going on you know and
you can have things like the Big Bang or
evolution or pick whatever sort of
scientific explanations you like in here
but damn you would say that's fine you
gotta explain how those themselves get
rolling and why they work the way that
they do now clamp a sand filo both say
this isn't going to wash why when you
look at this sort of reasoning do you
find this convincing yourself there has
to be some sort of coops because
otherwise you couldn't get the whole
thing going in the first place do you
find it convincing dirty do you find it
unconvincing yeah it could be a bit
lacking because what if you found a
different cause besides everything okay
couldn't you push the question further
back and say what was that cause right
at least with God you can say well yeah
by assumption he's the the beginning of
everything he's the under look it was
aliens right you know people want to say
sometimes aliens and I created the whole
cosmos that we know about is some sort
of super powerful race that's fine where
they come from see the reason why this
kind of argument gets made over and over
yet it's not just because people are you
know desperate to find you know some
sort of way to prove that comes in it
it's because there is some sort of there
is something within the nature of the
way that we look at the world we're
we're always able to ask them why
afterwards and we're not completely
happy until we get a final Y up to
chance yeah I mean that's that's one way
you could go and if you're like going to
be totally committed to that I guess
that would get you out of the problem
the trouble is once you do that it was
sort of like reverberate forward and
that everything was totally random isn't
it does that experience something I
don't think so Hume doesn't really worry
that song that much about that he says
look these arguments from from a priori
basis they just don't work you can
imagine things to be different and if
you can imagine them to be different
then you haven't proved anything with
necessity you know the other is another
problem with this too let's say you
actually do go through all of this and
you get God as being a necessary clause
is that
of God that most religious people have
is that a guy having a fraud of miracles
is that their God doing miracles within
this business probably not
all right I mean if you said everything
out well no you don't need miracles but
when you think about God and you think
about whether you want to believe in God
or not do you think yes I need to decide
whether there's a necessary cause to
everything that exists and you know the
whole basis of causality is that how you
frame it to yourself when you those of
you who go to church or you know or
synagogue or you know wherever a temple
you know do you do you say to yourself
all right now I'm going to pray to the
necessary being the ultimate cause of
things open up the you know the hymnal
to page 36 Oh necessary be we praise the
that as our tacos that's not that's not
a very rich conception of God maybe
that's not even the same conception of
God that religious people actually have
so that that's a problem right there and
India is not going to really play much
more role although than kicking it out
the arguments of the other tickets are
making so let's look at the argument
about Hume devotes much more room to
theory and this is an argument by
analogy and we talked about this last
time you know an example of the day
ology is dog is two cat as puppy is two
kitten right not goldfish not
sassafras tree you know kit you get the
right thing to fill in that spot you
guys did lots of these rumors of your
SATs or your AC tees or all the other
tests that they they constantly give you
guys can we make analogies between other
things well let's think about the
structure of analogy first whenever
you're making an argument from analogy
you're saying that you can do this let's
call them a and and you want to say a
Dax share some sort of common property
so how do you get there it's not just
enough to say well you know human beings
design things they're forgot design six
different axis you need some other terms
animating more these so you're saying
that because the relationship between
these is similar and these things
themselves are similar that you can go
from this to this this is the thing that
you don't actually know this is the
thing you don't have experience on the
percent you have experience over here
plenty in your life so
and you maybe have some experience of
this as well this is what you want to
find out about so if we're working with
this design argument here's basically
the way it goes when we look and you
know to make it contemporary let's use
an iPhone right other smart phones just
something whatever you like right and 20
years from now and who knows what we're
gonna actually have we could just solve
in some other piece of technology yeah
this earlier you could pick something
like a milk you know
grinding coffee or you pick anything
that you like you know we didn't have
these sort of things back in my time we
were lucky that we have the the old
retirees you know everything was very
highly pixelated and we thought it was
like you know magic but somebody
designed them right and you know you
were great grandparents generation my
grandparents generation they thought the
TV was just amazing stuff we sort of
just take it for granted right and your
kids are gonna look at the technologies
that you have and be like wow I can't
believe people actually use that sort of
thing back in the day you know I wish
mom and dad would shut up about you know
all this this stuff that they did that
was so cool back then because we all
know it's just you know run-of-the-mill
and why do we have that we need to have
experience of designing things and you
guys have designed some things right
you've probably taken some things apart
and made modifications to them even just
you know let's think butter your your
phones how did you
- the phone to be what it is that you
wanted it to be how do we do that sort
of thing
we don't generally take it apart because
that violates the warranty and you know
we don't know enough unless maybe some
of you do we don't know enough about
these things to actually work on it
without damaging though but what do you
do with your phone yeah yeah so you know
that the case is external but the
background itself you're monkeying
around at the phone so maybe it's your
your dog or a place that you've been
I've got my wife's picture you know the
background picture at least the one that
comes up at first and then I've got a
concert scene for another one but you
can't see the background picture and why
not what do we have in our Falls
Wow what's up well it's online apps
right we now who put those apps on your
phone you know right Apple put some of
the things on your iPhone how does it
work in a drive-in video of an Android
phone so come with no answer at all okay
so even even though the Android you know
super open source totally up to you they
say well everything's up to you except
for this bit right here that we're going
to put in but the rest of it we get in
well stupid undefined
ringtones yeah you customize those what
else we also had some yeah lots of music
I know that takes up most of space on my
phone and there's this other category
that you never quite figure out what it
is
sucks up memory and none of the forums
ever have a conclusive thing about that
now you may have experience of modifying
sort of things how many of you built
force when you were kids there's at
least no forts or pillow forts never
built a pillow for this with a couch and
stuff like that you're a designer right
did any of you take things apart like
your toaster or they fixed your bike or
now you can tell you're a good designer
and designer whether you have all all
the parts are gone when you're done
putting it back together or whether you
have what you know mechanical spare
parts which aren't really expect are cuz
they're supposed to be in the thing but
you didn't know where they went back yet
but you have a lot of experience of us
right when you take your car to the
mechanic used to be you could actually
work on your own cars but a bit not if
you can't do that very much
the mechanics hook it up the computers
and then then I figure out what's wrong
with it and I think they charge you good
money
why are they getting that money because
they're a designer they know how to how
to fix that sort of thing now what will
it be over here let's get rid of the
iPhone se now let's just say products
human human uses the word art let's say
technology that's easier to relate to
right because when we think art we think
of like going downtown and looking at
the Museum and standing and looking at a
painting or at some weird
incomprehensible sculpture and you know
what's the meaning of it he's not
talking about art in that sense he's
like my technology what would be the bee
over here we want to get to ultimately
God we know God need to make the iPhone
we know that we did yeah cause of the
iPhone know that cause the iPhone is we
Apple Steve Jobs yeah some lady Steve
Jobs waved his wand the iPhone came into
existence
yeah there's two ways we can go this we
can over here with the B part we can say
that it is the entire universe or we can
go a little bit smaller scale and we can
talk about minerals
you know mineral kingdom is kind of
interesting and if you have an interest
in geology for you know earth science
kind of cool stuff not really that
complicated those of you that we were
talking about this before a couple class
sessions before class when you get to
when you get away from physics itself
and get into chemistry and then you get
to something else that's a little bit
more complicated
what was it subject matter you're
dealing with life what is the science
that studies of living things biology
right my ology has got to be more
complicated than chemistry or physics
because you're dealing with higher level
principles you're dealing with much more
organized things now just think about
remember back in high school or middle
school looking at single-celled
organisms if you have a really good
microscope first you got to figure out
how to use the microscope right here
your eyelashes getting away doesn't
bless it doesn't work quite right but if
you actually get it to work right and
you can see the single-cell organism and
you can start to see the structure
inside of it isn't that fascinating
it's got so much structure in there it's
like a little machine hyrum says this is
a very popular to do those things and if
you think of these things as being like
machines it makes them very easy to
think about and manipulate and
conceptualize and make predictions about
and bacteria are very much like little
machines if you go even further down
viruses all viruses are is code inside
of a pro
container and that code goes out it gets
injected into a cell and it inserts
itself into the cell's DNA and then it
takes over the DNA and it makes it make
more viruses and that's what makes you
sick because their cells actually
explode and then shoot on all the sorts
of viruses that's just purely a machine
an organic machine but maybe you know we
saw this with the current maybe animals
and plants our machines as well maybe
your body is just an incredibly
complicated machine now can we make
stuff like that other than in sci-fi
movies yeah robot the exact same motion
right that's technology I'm talking
about actually Halloween made living
tissue you know with the sort of
complexity
I know we've created like meat in the
laboratory but it's not really meat it's
kind of a meaty cannot like thing yeah
well they have actually repurposed
viruses for other gold
yes we're able to monkey around with the
stuff and change its programming so to
speak maybe news you have a genetic
things like you know we do that all the
time with agricultural things all right
we did we want corn not to be affected
by a particular clog so the corn throws
the point we've put in the G and the
corn and develops a poison to that bog
but that doesn't mean that we actually
designed the thing that's up we just
found it and then it's sort of like you
coming across an iPhone in the bathroom
and it doesn't have a lock but let's say
it has a lock on you figure out the why
do you say well I don't like this Apple
this app and I have this one good step I
don't like their pictures I'll put my
own pictures and their music is a lawful
what's my home again and change the name
on the phone too
I'll change the number the iPhone itself
still exists though right and it still
has the same basic structure coding all
that you just messed around with the
surface level cloning would be taking
something that already exists out there
and making more of it using this sort of
logic yeah I mean we're gonna get to a
point eventually where some of these
arguments about you know God being so
much of a greater designer might get
more implausible because of our
capacities if we go back to like Humes
time this stuff was just like complete
science fiction you could look at like a
human being and you could cut them open
and say wow complicated structure we're
not able to do that and then this would
be more possible yeah so the only terms
of where technology could do on par to
say just creating actual Orion is if
using no biological means like say
taking from an already existing so just
purely from elements you created life
yeah and if you wanted to go further
with it I guess
imagine trying to create an animal that
has never existed before from the ground
out with like everything that an animal
has got the whole nervous system the
endocrine system the circulatory system
all these complicated things and with no
blueprint whatsoever that small work at
the scene
yeah I'll probably be the way to go yeah
that's an interesting question that's
one that Hugh doesn't consider we can
stir yeah we destructive worry about
that once it starts getting particularly
complicated and that's why we have some
sci-fi things for like you know machines
become sentient
and then once once they do generally
once the machines become sentient more
troubled right because them they're not
happy about the fact that we've been
slaved them and they start killing us
and Skynet takes over the matrix takes
over I mean those are really interesting
let me let me get back to this because I
want to get plow through this this part
so the end look we can see how design
works over there we look at these things
over to here whether it's the entire
universe or whether it's you know
animals human beings stuff like that
would say incredibly well designed you
know evidence of some sort of
intentionality you know and then we saw
that this is not a new argument this is
made back in ancient times right I saw
that with Cicero's nature we got the
conclusion of this is supposed to be
what God is some sort of designer that
so not only do we know that God exists
we know that God is in some way a lot
like human beings so there's a
similarity that we can count on between
human beings who design things and God
who designs the whole big ball of wax
and everything in it even the beings
that are capable of designing other
beings now how did that sound to you
is that it is that a plausible argument
more plausible than this sort of very
abstract argument from causality that
Damian was making this clamp these
arguments a lot of people make these
arguments still today though the entire
intelligent design
movement is focused around this sort of
reasoning and intelligent design
something very different than
creationist creationism is like you know
yeah God created the world in seven days
and we got to find some way to pack the
dinosaurs in with the cavemen and you
know everything has to happen within
this very limited timeframe intelligent
design is willing to say yeah you can
have evolution you can have all these
other things but you've got a designer
behind the scenes planning everything
out running the show
and that's why we have this incredible
complexity that's able to work so you
guys spend as plausible you find it
implausible what do you think do you
agree with this part right do you think
you can go from that part to this part
yeah can you go beyond it so what what
would be beyond yeah that actually does
come up you noticed phyllo says look if
you want to do this you know they've got
me a cause for a cause for quads
business sort of thing then you got to
explain where did God get this the way
he puts it is Kevin designs and how does
a designer design they have ideas in
their mind right and when you're
designing something there's some sort of
words or the ideas in your mind
okay yeah well you could imagine
something new but you're right there has
to be some elements of something that
you've you have some prior experience
and human call those ideas in your mind
how do those ideas get ordered in God's
mind and clan theists has a response to
this that you might not find it entirely
convincing he says look you don't have
to push it back any further than that
once you've got that you've got a God
designing things good enough we don't
need to worry about how God got his
ideas in his mind God will take care of
that business now that may make it less
convincing for you when you hear the
Anthes talking like that or you might
say yeah okay that makes sense to me but
that is that's that's his response to
fillo asking that very same question
which is you know they got the natural
question to ask we just talked about
this we have a tendency to keep on
asking why clamping seems to say at a
certain point the why you don't need to
answer now let's think about some of the
problems with this so here's one big
problem do we really experience design
in nature we experience design of things
that we know are designed by human
beings you know I'm looking around at
clothing each of your each of the things
that you're wearing unless you have like
some thing that was you know totally
random my mom when I was a kid to make
our own clothes and the stuff that she'd
make she was you know a good seamstress
but it was the 70s just horrible things
you know didn't go with anything The
cuts were always kind of weird you know
but you guys don't have what I'm
guessing your store-bought clothes I do
too
all these are the way they are we know
that they're the way they are because
somebody designed them and if I if I get
too fat I can like how
like you know thin again I can like have
this taken in somebody who's redesigning
it alright riding by some you know
things that fit me better right same
thing happens to use get get bigger
taller you had to grow a lot of clothes
shoes things like that do we really have
a lot of experience about this over here
we don't have experience with God and
this has to begin with we didn't see God
designing things saying yeah the Potamus
should be about this big and how many
toe should we give that we don't have
any experience of that we're just
presuming that do we have experience of
design in nature not really so that's
kind of a problem another big problem
that human points out through Fela is
these arguments from analogy really only
work when the things that were
analogizing about are pretty similar to
each other is a human being pretty
similar to God
the way that they normally conceive of
God or God pretty similar to a human
being or is there such a gulf such a
distance between these two terms that
comparisons start to get really shaky
start to break down start to become no
longer certainly very probable blessing
but start to become very weak sort of
smear suggestions that's a big problem
and where he's going to go with this is
where people go he says look you can
propose alternate models you can come up
with different notions of how this this
whole process would work so let's think
about this for a moment we get God and
then we've got the universe
are we going to get the kind of God that
we want out of this necessarily or could
we think of alternate ways of conceiving
this there's two ways that you can go
depending on whether you look at the
design part or whether you're gonna look
at the designer yeah well you say that
human beings a designer who designed the
news yeah yeah human doesn't doesn't go
into that in this piece he treats that
in something he calls the natural
history of religion piece that he didn't
publish you know in his lifetime because
we were raised a lot higher than they
already had raised against him but that
would be a different sort of sort of
issue that wouldn't really have to do
with with this so much a separate
problem tree
the universe is designed is the universe
should we understand the universe on the
the basis of it being like a bunch of
machines or a bit like being one
gigantic machine or should we perhaps
say that the universe if we want to buy
into this sort of thing is more like
perhaps a vegetable undergoing growth or
like an animal undergoing reproduction
that seems just as plausible as what
Fela was saying just as plausible
because equally impossible he has the
universe being one gigantic machine so
you know we know that machines have ten
designers but how do vegetables grow do
they do they have to have a designer to
come along and like you know okay carrot
let's let's you know take her around
with you now we got to add a little bit
down here yeah
yeah they're there you're like tinkering
with like you said the some of the the
thing but the basic straw that carrot
still remains a carrot right if it
becomes so different than a carrot we
got to call it something else like I
mean even if it like started doing
things that we see in cartoons like
carrot suddenly grows carrot legs and
starts becoming a madness and trying to
eat us you know we would still say I'm
being attacked by a giant carrot
like we do in cartoons sometimes but
let's say we're not genetically altering
these things vegetables you just plant
the seed right now that it kinda grows
by itself I mean you got a weed around
it you know what weeds to get it and
gonna protect it from insides but for
the most part it's it's sort of on its
own and don't plants reproduce more or
less on their own they don't even all
reproduced by seed right well how do
your lilies reproduce well the thing
they didn't make little bits of seed but
that doesn't act that's not how they
usually spread how they tend to spread
roots right there's Brotherhood system
out a new leaf thing pops up here and
after a while it's an independent thing
rhizomes wheat almost so maybe the
universe is more like that or maybe it's
more like like any animal you know
having all these sort of things going on
the Stoics seem to think of it that way
I didn't that back in cicero's dialogue
so if that's the case then you know you
don't need a designer and I don't
remember whether it's Leontes or a Dan
yet points out well you still have to
kind of explain the problem of where did
that I think it is Dania where did that
vegetable come from the first place he
wants to go back to a priori artists you
know why does the vegetable
why the lady animals reproduce the video
but you know imagine this for a moment
imagine that the universe is soar like a
a seed from some sort of cosmic tree and
it grows and eventually becomes mature
and then produces new little seed lit
universes of its own and they go off and
they produce themselves you don't need a
guy back there true do you it just ready
happens right so you could take the
designer out but let's say we want to go
with there being a designer
so this is where filo brings up what I
call a bunch of different models and
these are kind of interesting thoughts
to think about filo doesn't actually
believe he's just proposing these as
possibilities and he's saying look if
you wanna if you want to say that this
design thing is going to work these are
just as plausible it has anything else
so in one section he gives us six of
these so he says maybe the world is
perfect right maybe the world actually
is this gigantic perfect machine but how
do machinists work do they actually come
up with everything in their head on
their own anybody have a you know family
members who work in tool-and-die or in
production lines and factories or stuff
like that or or designers for anything
using a template us right you guys use
templates I think sometimes in writing
did your writing constructors give you
any templates no it's too bad cuz
they're hand you know but you're gonna
write this kind of paper
here's how to start it here's how to
hand it here's all the guts in between
you know that's a template when you have
to write a report about something and
it's got been off fill in this part here
this part here that's giving you a
template it's telling you what to do at
what point we do that when we design
things as well alright first put the
plate down now drill the holes in it now
put that plate on top of this plate now
put a bolt through it
you guys have followed templates when
you follow instructions putting things
together right boys later on it's gonna
become Ikea things like eeeh
so maybe the world is like that why do
we have to think of God as being like
this you know super great designer why
could he just have gotten a template
from some other place and applied it and
here's our all maybe there is another
world that you know turned out to be
like you know the best practices world
and all the other all the gods say yeah
that's the kind of world we're gonna
make here we go
I've got it now I'll just put it
together follow the instructions
hippos will go over here giraffes go
over here
don't put the monkeys right next to the
Lions because they'll eat it you know
feeding monkeys left after a while
palm trees go here okay I've got it all
set up
isn't that plausible doesn't that be
equally plausible as a guy who actually
like designed every single thing by
himself you think about you don't copy
people if people are into model trains
some of them get really really into
those dioramas do they make every single
thing by themselves are they sometimes
copied from other places
here's another with that so that's the
first model maybe here's another one
maybe this world is the last world in a
whole bunch of trials and this turns out
to be the best of the worlds that was
made because the other ones were all
screwed up in some ways and so God make
them and then after you look at them for
a while and be like nah let me let me
erase and start again you know like when
you're writing the paper in the old
fashioned days you know y'all do it on
their computer how so you just delete
right but in the old-fashioned days you
tape it on a typewriter you look at it
you'd be like now that's crap you throw
it away when you see movies were like
somebody's got like a whole trash can
and it's full of all scripted balled up
attempts maybe this is the one that made
it through so the design in it is just a
function of God having honed his skills
over life maybe young this world wasn't
designed by a god maybe it was designed
that whole committee of gods or teams I
mean you guys don't like group projects
I know right
how many of you like your projects do
you like their projects but you were in
the military though so you actually have
some experience with groups that
actually work okay
most students don't like your projects
because some of the students slack off
and parts don't always fit together but
when you actually have experience of
being on a team that actually everybody
is on the same page it's kind of fun
it's enjoyable and I hope that in your
careers that are coming up you will have
better experiences with doing group
projects because it can be quite but
useful and sometimes people bring more
and more the process well that's the
case though then we're no longer talking
about a god who's perfect we're talking
about a whole bunch of gods each of whom
contributes a little thing that could
bring up all sorts of interesting issues
he brings up another problem that came
from the group's maybe the gods are so
much like human beings that they
actually
do sexually maybe some of the things in
the world are a product of the gods
getting it on with various parts of the
cosmos or each other you know if you
look at the old Egyptian cosmologies or
some of the Greek ones or various things
or you know you could pick other things
like you know Norse mythology one of the
gods I forget which one kills this giant
and then makes parts of the earth out of
the Giants you need to come up with all
sorts of examples like this model five
maybe this this world is actually the
first effort by some young guy who's
trying his best but isn't very skilled
yet and that's why all you know there's
all the problems that we may encounter
maybe some of the other guys even make
fun of his his his project you know he's
sort of like the kid is not very good in
the science fair that could that's a
possibility or you like poor little guy
you know or maybe I mentioned this
before maybe it's a very old God who is
actually way past his prime and was
senile and after he made this worldly
die and the world is just sort of kept
going on usually gods would stay more
involved with it stay on top of their
projects but this God you know just
wasn't with it and after he died the
world was kept going on that's why
things are the way they are isn't any
one of these models just as plausible as
the model that is being performed by
clampets
because if you get to the concept of God
you have to
how this dog died yeah I mean forgot to
diet some pathologies you know Norse
mythology they're all going to die
except for just a few of the very
adamant Ragnarok and the Babylonian
mythologies they kill each other you
know man is actually made in the ANU
mulisch out of blood
I forget his name one of the guys who
was a big troublemaker so they kill them
and the guys are like yeah you know we
need some people to serve us because
because this this thing of us serving
each other is not going to fly any more
clearly this leaks all sorts of problems
let's create a race to serve us so they
take the blood of this guy and mix it
together with dirt
and then you got human beings so there's
the you know you can conceive of gods -
because because people have thought of
that
maybe that's - dancer for more for call
it a conception let me use the mix like
about one of those things then we'll
finish up now Janey accuses Korean
thieves of trying to make God too much
like human beings and he says really we
can't know very much about God clay
anthe says no God is very much like
human beings that we experience that's
why we can't in fact know things about
God clan thiis is going to go even
further and he is actually been say in
this case God
simple the perfect all-powerful follows
from that as well and he says God's not
all-powerful there's evil in the world
and parkus God couldn't prevent all of
it if you start making God more and more
like a human being if your conception of
God was like that then you probably have
to go to something like this the Klan
'they says if we want to understand how
God thinks we can't say that God's mind
is completely simple because we'd have
no way to understand that what that
means I mean think about your minds you
have all sorts of ideas they change over
time your ideas can a jar with each
other or coincide with each other
supposedly according to traditional
Christian theology God's mind is so
totally simple that he sees past present
and future all at the same time remember
when we looked at Augustine you know
who's that that sort of thing how can
that even make sense
clay a piece is saying God mind must be
much more like our minds so God could
undergo change God would not be perfect
God could actually like it better or
perhaps get worse God would not have
infinite power infinite knowledge this
is a very interesting conception of God
there are some people out there who have
sort of run with this idea
it's not a majority conception ISM most
people when they they wanna say you know
God exists they want it to be an
infinite perfect completely simple God
they are from an all eternity and all
that but then you have a hard time
explaining things like well you know why
is there evil in the world then this
traditional problem of evil that Fela
will bring them clean things will try to
deal with clay on this is what you can
get out of that just by saying well
God's not perfect he's really good just
not perfect so the world is pretty good
but not as good as it could be if God
was even more powerful but if God was
more powerful we would be less able to
understand what God is less able to make
sets out less and less able to be sure
that there is such a guy you can tell
Dania doesn't really like this idea you
can tell them feel it wasn't by it
either so you know that's that's
probably a good sign that Hume himself
doesn't buy the same yet but he puts it
in the mouth at one of his interlocutors
because it's it's where clamp these
ideas ultimately lead so he puts you in
a lot of dilemmas in this if you're
gonna buy these starting points well
that's gonna lead here if you're gonna
buy these dirty points that's gonna lead
here buy these at leads here and none of
these are alternatives than a
traditional Christian theist could be
happy with so the ultimate conclusion
for humans dialogues unnatural religion
which Hume himself doesn't spell out is
that none of these arguments are
actually going to work
none of these traditional ways of
understanding photography rely very
rhetorically powerful way of putting it
together again you know up to you
whether you buy this stuff not I think
there's a lot of gaps in Humes own
reasoning about this sort of thing but
very powerful challenge for the very
notion that being able to prove anything
about God so have a good weekend